what do Gaza and Ferguson have to do
with one another if you ask the black
and Palestinian artists and activists
who've just released a new solidarity
video a lot prominent figures like Miss
Lauren Hill Danny Glover and Alice
Walker came together in this
three-minute video with one strong
message when I see them I see us harass
we tortured dehumanized stopped and
frisked searched at checkpoints
administrative detention youth
incarceration the poem highlights the
similarities and the violence and
struggles faced by both communities
Palestinian legal scholar and organizer
knew derided COTS got the idea for the
video during the summer of 2014 when
Gaza was being bombed and Ferguson
erupted in protests after the police
killing of unarmed 18-year old Michael
Brown I asked her what's the
significance of solidarity between black
Americans and Palestinians and it's a
solidarity movement that has been
steadily growing
earlier this year activists from groups
like black lives matter the dream
defenders and the black youth project
100 among others took a historic trip to
the occupied West Bank in Israel the
purpose of the trip was for young black
leaders to connect with Palestinians
living under Israeli military occupation
so what are the parallels the two
communities find in common here's what
detroit-based writer and activist
Christian Davis Bailey who co-wrote the
poem in the video told me one of the
biggest parallels I see between black
and Palestinian people is that we're
each fighting really large systems or
racism militarized control and state
control and we also see that violence
against us is justified at the same time
that our protests are criminalized or
demonized and one of the on-the-ground
campaigns between black and Palestinian
solidarity groups targets g4s a British
security company that provides
technology for American and Israeli
prisons
already they've seen major institutions
like the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation the United Methodist Church
and Columbia University divest from g4s
so can joint solidarity campaigns
ultimately lead to policy changes when
it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict it feels like it's always the
same story